>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Managing Devices
>> Judy: Hi, I'm Judy Dixon,
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover managing devices.
To access the cartridges or
USB flash drives connected
to your computer, choose the Manage
Devices button from the Main Menu.
You will be presented with a list of
devices connected to your computer
and the number of books
on each device.
Select the button associated with
the device you wish to examine.
From this screen you can access
information about the amount
of available space on
the drive and the amount
of space currently being
used, you can verify that none
of the book files are missing or
corrupted, and you can delete books
from your device or change
the name of your device.
>> NVDA: 3 books are using
323.7 MB of space 33%.
331.9 MB free space on drive I Jet
Flash Transcend 1 GB USB Device.
List Arcadia checkbox not checked.
Author Groff, Lauren.
Status has not been validated.
Check selected.
Blue check box selected,
not checked.
Author Steel Danielle.
Status has not been validated.
Checked. Dodgers check
box selected, not checked.
Author Beverly, Bill.
Status has not been validated.
Checked. Validate books button.
Validating book one of three.
Arcadia. Multiline.
BARD Express dialog box.
2 books are valid with no
missing or corrupt files.
The following books have
corrupt files: Blue.
Ok button.
Device contents.
Validate books button.
Lists. Arcadia checkbox checked.
Author Crace, Jim.
Status Valid Book.
Selected not checked.
Blue checkbox check selected.
Author Steel, Danielle.
Status Book has corrupt files.
Dodgers checkbox check selected.
Author Beverly, Bill.
Status Valid Book not checked.
Validate books button.
Delete books button.
BARD Express dialogue.
Are you sure you want
to delete one book?
Yes button alt + y.
>> Judy: If you want to change
the name of your device,
use the edit box labeled
Volume label.
For more information on
transferring books, searching BARD,
and managing your wish list see
the other tutorials in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.